now joining me in the studio is the
Shadow Chancellor John McDonald hello
thank you for being with us and before
we move on to the other issues I'm quite
keen to get your thoughts on the report
we just watched about anti-semitism
within the labor party or allegations of
it and I was really struck when speaking
to some of the Jewish community that
they feel almost a sense of personal
betrayal that labor is a party that they
felt allied to for many decades
yeah it was their party and and now they
feel that that's changed do you think
they have a point it's a tragedy it's
absolute tragedy I could weep about it I
really could because I've spoken to a
number of those people as well and the
other tragedy is we're now led by
someone who's possibly one of the most
foremost anti-racist campaigners that
we've had in our political history his
parents met John mccords parents met in
the cable street campaign which was to
defend the Jewish community against the
fascists Allah so I think we we've just
we've got to open the dialog again and
overcome these problems and I believe
our party and I don't want to I don't
believe in being complacent about this I
believe our party is still the
anti-racist party that I joined I think
there's anti-semitism in our community
and it will pervade all our institutions
and we've got to root it out the shock
for me is the four figures last year
1,300 anti-semitic incidents hate crimes
reported across our whole community now
labor should be at the forefront of
confronting that instead were involved
in this internal well internal
examination and exploration of what's
been going on in the last 12 months
around kendama stand we've got to close
that down and move on with Ken
Livingstone and I'm interested in your
own personal view here not that sort of
party line do you think he should have
been expelled from the party look Ken
lose the last year I made it clear to
him he should have apologized
immediately and he didn't he did when I
repeated and I was quite angry about
that I've known Ken I was his deputy on
the GRC we've worked together we've
fallen out of number of times as well
from almost straight with him he should
have apologized this
came about because my Parma trip private
secretary nice char made a statement
which was appalling
about sending Jews took from Israel to
America I immediately asked her to stand
down and she did what did she do she
apologized immediately realized the
mistake that she'd made and was shocked
by it apologized immediately met the
Jewish community and has been a plotted
since for learning the lesson that's
what I want Ken to do there's a thing
within the Jewish faith that was
transferred into as well into the
Christian religion which is honest
contrition followed by forgiveness and
reconciliation that's what I wanted to
happen that's what I want to happen now
quite honestly so I'm still a bit
unclear though do you think he should
have been expelled because he hasn't
apologized positive I think people are
surprised that the what happened out of
the hearings that took place I'd like to
know what legal advice was provided what
will now happen is that the NEC will
consider this matter again and there'll
be further consideration no matter I'm
not saying anything now that will
prejudge that or prejudice what will
come out of it I've got my advice to Ken
again I say this as an old ally of this
apologize it this argument about
historical fact there's not the issue
the issue is you've deployed it to
justify what was an anti-semitic
statement by now she'll just apologize
now and I tell you Jewish members the
community will accept contrition and
will forgive and move on but until we
get some form of apology I don't think
we can and the the behavior of the last
week just it's hard to come to terms
with we've got to get out there as a
party in our campaigning against racism
in our society anti-semitism on the rise
which is appalling but also only only a
month ago a few weeks ago thirty people
pounced upon a young asylum seeker
nearly kicked him to death
our party should be leading the campaign
to tackle racism our society and we've
been diverted into this and we've got to
reestablish our credentials as an
anti-racist party now moving on I'm I'm
keen to get your views on the other
really pressing issue this week which is
Syria we've seen the defense secretary
coming out today to say Russia is
responsible by proxy for the 87 deaths
in that chemical attack in
Syria is he right well what we should
have had immediately rather than Trump
going to bombing we should have an
immediate inquiry about the well the use
of sarin gas again by is Russia
responsible do you think well I think
Russia has a role to play because
they've propped up the Assad regime all
the way through but the only way I think
we're going to get rid of us had is what
was happening before the bombing which
was actually for the first time the US
and Russia beginning to build their
relationship in which our strategy
around Syria could be developed the
bombing I think has set that back what
should have happened is a proper inquiry
under UN auspices then a debate within
the UN and then a UN the UN used then to
develop the strategy for peace
negotiated peace in Syria and what we've
got to do now from our country from the
UK we can play a role in that by putting
pressure on all sides now to get back to
the Geneva talks you talk about the UN
everyone of course would love to see
some kind of UN resolution agreement
going forward but let's get real it's
not going to happen is it Russia has
already built exactly no certainly it's
not a meteor no it isn't it isn't it
immediately it isn't but it's bizarre
this Trump and Putin relationship that
was developing could have enabled this I
think to step back from the bombing
rather than immediately bomb then
actually have a proper inquiry and drawn
Russia in because I actually think
there's no way we'll get rid of us out
unless there's Russian agreement and I
think the potential there has been
destroyed as a result of this bombing
now in response to those US airstrikes
that were launched we've had some rather
different should we say responses from
some people within your own party the
deputy leader Tom Watson welcomed it as
a direct and proportionate response
Jeremy Corbyn the leader said it risks
intensifying and multi-sided conflict
which side do you want
jeromy's because I believe that there
shouldn't have been born it was torn up
some ramen well I think he was but look
we've just Tom's disagreed with us on
bombing of Syria all the way through we
had a free vote last year and he took a
different view and I respect that for
you I don't condemn him I think like
that I respect it but it's a different
view from both mine and Jeremy's and
others within the party we believe that
bombing was precipitous there should
have been a proper investigation there
should have been hopefully then the
start of the Geneva talks
again this may have set us back I'm
hoping it hasn't but the talks have got
to start soon we will not we will not
get a settlement in Syria as a result of
bombing we'll get as a negotiated
settlement at some stage and if we can
bring Russia Iran side injury of course
that means a settlement without Assad
very hopeful isn't it it is bring Russia
hot sauce it is but at the same time
what you've got to do is judge every
step so you do not alienate potential
allies for the future the bombing I
think has set us back I think it could
have been it was precipitous and I think
it could have been handled with more
care certainly because of the Trump new
relationship with Putin that was
development about the bombing though was
a direct response to a deadly chemical
weapons attack that killed 87 people
including children which was absolutely
appalling as you say I mean I'm just
trying to wrap my brains and think of
any time when labor would be prepared to
intervene so the moment it feels today
there's almost no point having an army
if there was later I'm not I'm not a
pessimist or not a pacifist party but
what you have to do when would you have
to take a judgment about when physical
force is necessary and you've got to
exhaust every other Avenue here's the
tragedy today America is bombed as a
result of the use of gas and yet Syria
Assad is bombing again today with barrel
bombs again so actually it hasn't
stopped the bombing in fact it might
have actually put off the opportunity of
negotiated settlement my views there
should have been a time for a proper
inquiry though the results of that
inquiry properly exposed negotiations
and back to Geneva I think there was
potential there we've got to get back to
that that's why I think actually Boris
Johnson should be in Moscow now I think
he should be there saying he was wrong
there and I think he was I think he
should be in Moscow now saying to the
Russians just how appalling this
situation isn't the role that they
should play we've got to be frank with
them we shouldn't just allow the
Americans to go off and do that we
should be doing that I so do you think
that he's effectively bound to pressure
from America then I don't know we need
to ask him that I mean is to be honest
with us about that as well and they need
to be straightforward but look we
shouldn't be well we shouldn't be
basically he's being directed by America
but whether we ought not with whether we
are or not he should be there making the
case so Russia just condemned
of course but then also saying the proof
in whether or not they're serious about
the future piece is back to Geneva in
the talks he should be saying that on
our behalf firmly now local elections
are looming latest polling is let's
people aren't pretty terrible at the
moment let's have a look at oh no I'm
sorry I'm just being told that we don't
have the graphics screen always very
smooth running here as always and but
what I was going to say is that last
week Jeremy Corbyn said to a reporter
when asked about his leadership it's
your responsibility to make sure the
opposition voices heard it's your
failings do you think the media is to
blame for labour being 20 points behind
in the poll what Jeremy was saying was
look the media should now report us
accurately and reporters fairly there's
been a number of independent reports
that said it quite forcefully it's you I
I know because he was interrupted so
often and actually no one was actually
talking about the real issues and we
have a an audience there who were
getting up or asking real questions
about what's that mean schools closed
your sure start centers by the
Conservatives the loss of 50,000
teachers last year those serious issues
were being raised and all unfortunately
unfortunately all the number of
reporters were talking about with Gerry
korva standing in the polls and what are
you quite rightfully said is let's talk
about the real issues that concern
people but if you want to do with those
real issues you have yeah of course we
of course we didn't remember when Jeremy
took over we were 12 to 14 points behind
in the polls in the polls and then yes
and yes so it was some one poll I think
it was it was you saying there wasn't
seriously saying that the average of the
poll what I'm saying is before he took
over we well behind in the polls as well
in his first six months actually we got
the situation we were either just before
but just behind all virtually level with
the Tories and then we had another
leadership election yet again I'm hoping
they're not becoming annual all that's
but another leadership election and
people won't vote for a party that looks
divided so what we're saying to our own
party we've got to unite and we've got
presented United Front because the
issues were raising what's interesting
when you poll the issues in our policies
they're extremely popular
so what's preventing people translating
that into strength in the polls and it's
partly because they see us as divided so
if we unite which I think we are doing
there are a number of issues
particularly around brexit you'll see us
rise
now one last question I'm interested to
get your answer on this when you were
first appointed chair Chancellor I think
people were expecting a kind of radical
manifesto it has some of your policies
are almost to the right of Ed Miliband
so what's happened is that socialist
firebrand and what's happened is that
I've engaged in one of them I suppose
one the most the biggest engagement
process is with our members or with the
electorate of the last 12 months
listening to them talking to them about
the real issues have you tamed your
views no no sir let me finish what I'm
saying is I've been touring around the
country for the last 18 months listening
to people what their ideas are floating
some of the ideas that we've got and
preparing I think extremely radical
program you'll see that rolled out in
the next few months and I believe
actually it won't just be radical but it
will demonstrate actually the popularity
of it as well okay and I you just look
at what happened last week when we
suggested free school meals and I'd pay
for them by v.a.t.s poetry or just
that's as an extension of what the
coalition's put well it was radical in
the sense that we're implementing it on
the base of a redistribution of wealth
and that's what it is and that's worry
about as a party what we're about to the
redistribution of wealth and power from
those that so basically are the richest
in our country the most powerful to the
rest of the people that's the radical
program you'll be seeing rolled out
between now and the next one okay
radical program to come John McDonnell
thank you very much